anyways what's going on guys how are you
guys all doing so today we are here on
my merging account surprisingly enough
as it is a merchant video so we're here
with the first merch of the episode so
nonetheless hope you guys enjoy and
we're going to get right into all of the
all of the merchants that I'm about to
do over the next couple days so we're
gonna start with this alright there we
go so my to eternal crystals I bought
for four mill and 10k they should sell
back for 4.1 mil each will make about
200k off of that literally hours later
and finally I sold one of the eternal
crystals like bro what is going on I'm
gonna make my money back in like 50k in
the matter of an hour or probably three
to four hours this is just depressing
alright so I'm waking up in the morning
hopefully some of the stuff bought in
and out of it oh okay well my eternal
crystals sold that's all I really needed
alright so the guide price for
treasonous rings tells me that it is 18
milk and our 18 mill 1.8 mill I just
bought one off of the GE for 1886 so I'm
going to go ahead and drop that down by
a GP so I can sell that back but other
than that the trees in the streams we're
gonna throw in a pretty big offer for
1801 kay and I'll throw in I can I can
get four of them which is nice about all
these buy and sell I should be able to
make my 320k off of all which would be
really nice merch there we go so another
treasonous ring bunch gonna listed back
up these things are taking so much
longer than I thought they would I did
that a couple days ago and they weren't
this long at all but nonetheless I'll be
going here in about an hour so if I need
to give these things time to sell I
guess I can do that alright so two more
the [__] Rangers bought however we do
not have any sold yet so I'm probably
gonna drop the price on this I don't
know if anyone would have undercut me
because I would have undercut the buy
price too but maybe the dudes selling it
just did it to try to sell it quicker I
don't know we're gonna have to drop the
price though because I'm not trying to
get stuck with these because this is
actually a pretty high price to buy them
all at so there we go so we finally got
one of the treasonous rings to sell I
might have to up the buy offer for these
are not entirely
sure but I will be leaving here in a
second so I don't get to buy them and
it's not gonna be the end of the world
but we will see if we can you can grab
at least one of them maybe so we pretty
much instantly just bought one so their
answers that question that was probably
honestly like five seconds I stopped the
recording and here we hard back again
alright so one of them bought
nonetheless I gotta go I'll be back on
here in about a day's time so hopefully
these things so if not I'll be stuck
with something I'm about to lose 600
cans oh yeah alright so there we go four
of the Rings have already bought we're
going to list them up for the price of
which I've already looked up just a
second ago in the video but I forgot so
182 for 500 cuz you might have dropped
the prices a little bit so something off
for that that's seven point three which
means maybe 120km that I'm gonna find
some different items to merge here a
little bit but uh yeah I'll be back here
in a second
three of the Rings have sold and one has
bought alright so this may be one of the
more risky merges of this episode but
I'm going to see what eternal crystals
go for in hopes that there's a pretty
decent margin on them and there is
without a doubt if I can't buy one for
three point seven and I bought and I
sold this for three nine oh my goodness
there's a hell of a margin on this one
eternal crystal has sold problem is is I
do want to sell these real quick so I
could be able to buy to eternal crystals
so I'm gonna try to sell these for the
price that I bought them at hopefully
they will indeed sell and they did for
just a little over what I bought them
out so I made like 300 GP the only
reason I sold those because it's gonna
allow me to buy another eternal crystal
which will be by far and away more
profitable than so I'm just gonna go
three seven oh okay there we go so
surprisingly enough one of these that
bought or maybe unsurprisingly enough as
I did find out that that was a margin
but one of these have bought which means
now I will be able to sell it for more
than likely a 250 K margin that is
insane alright so thought about it a
little bit realize the only way I'm
gonna be able to find this eternal
crystal pricess you actually try to buy
one and I'm just going to put in the
price of which that I have my other one
and then we will see what the actual
price is for this so one bar
here 3 8 8 8 k there we go so I'll throw
both of these in for that right so as
you can see what my cache deck and by
what this thing says I did so back one
eternal crystal however the other one
has taken a lot of time to get so I feel
as if I'm going to just go and lower the
price and leave these things alone
because people just keep undercutting
each other on it and I'm just not about
it I've sat here for like two hours with
that all for him I'm not I'm not doing
the same or well about time but this
thing's sold I think I might be done
with these just because I don't know
what to buy them at I don't know what
they sell or buy for and I don't really
want to check because it's just been
stupidly annoying to try to buy and sell
these alright so I actually found some
margins on these treasonous rings so
1786 so we're gonna sell for 1815 pretty
much I'm gonna undercut him just because
you know it's high roll so 7.26 from
seven one four four so we made 120 k I'm
looking to get to the 10 mil mark at
least by the end of this video there
could be a lot more to come though I
have no clue right now alright so there
we give three out of four of them have
sold I'm gonna up the price in this a1 7
8 7 just because I have a feeling
someone undercut me alright so there we
go
all of these rings have now bought so
let's just grab those we'll have some up
for under this cuz someone obviously
undercut me so we'll go one eight one
three I believe alrighty then
so came back before the night was over
and I'm going to just go ahead and buy a
ring so I can know what to sell these
that overnight typically I like to be
able to put in an offer for some stupid
[__] overnight for a pretty decently
long amount of time however I think I
put my buy limit on this so I would
transfer over the money to another
account and do it but realistically I'm
just going to do it on another account
actually you know what I'm gonna say
[__] it because I just sold that
treasonous ring back on my other account
right now there's a 6k margin right
there that's not gonna stay I'm just
gonna listen up for pretty much the
price that we had the Matt I'm gonna
listen up with that bright so this is
the moment that I wake up and hope these
[__] rings sold and this is the
moment that I
depressed are you kidding me alright so
there we up all of the Rings have sold
it wasn't uh wasn't by far my most
profitable merch but uh made you know
negative six K on each one so we'll find
another item like alright so I tried to
do a quick March before I have to go to
work I got twelve forty six of them so
I'll be able to flip them for forty five
GP margin as you can see here three
three nine o things better sold let's
just make sure they did indeed did so
got no problems right now gotta get over
this time no mark and now I know it
didn't work for me the best earlier this
episode however I am going back to it
and that is the eternal Chris alright so
while I may be just logging into RS I am
actually just getting that eternal quick
so I'm gonna lower the price though so
I'm gonna go to three nine nine nine
nine whatever alright so there we go
after about half an hour one of these
sold
I actually just logged on and came back
after watching the Cavs game for a
little bit marching game for right now
tie ball game
looking pretty sick there we go so we
got both of them to sell realistically
these things take too long to [__]
get so I'm just gonna I'm gonna change
the item attire that I'm doing it so
about to go to this random work meeting
I have I don't I don't understand why
but I'm gonna sell us back so one seven
nine eight there we go
gonna make back our money that we lost
and hopefully the rest will buy when I'm
gone or at least some I just want to
make some money off these things alright
so definitely result I did not expect I
was gone for about fifty minutes and all
four rings bought however this one did
not sells oh not a good sign so give it
a little bit then I looked up the OS
buddy or RS buddy guy price realize that
I was off by 10 K still a solid merch
though so there we are we sold two of
them already
hey they both sold however none of them
have Bob which kind of leaves me a
little hopeless as far as treasonous
rings go however we have not had two ten
no mark there we go so where you gonna
find ourselves another item because
these margins are coming down
I just like to change so let's go find
something region bracelets were fail
literally put them in for 10k over
number by I said [__] it so here we are
go into bed open for the best expecting
literally nothing at all
unsurprisingly enough none of them but
sometimes actually learn something god
damn it there we go so actually did find
another item gilded plate links are
actually merging for eight right there
we go so one of them bought and one of
them sold they bought in the opposite
order of someone trying to undercut me
though so that's actually a good thing
one of these sold and one of these five
in that order so I believe someone is
checking out the price so I'm gonna up
it just a little bit to two nine seven
three alright so another one bought so
they're just gonna be a matter of time
until we can sell all these to him it
here we go so both of our gilded cage
shields bought I'm urging this on the
side just because you know something to
do it gives me a little bit of profit so
gonna sell those on for five three eight
Kent and let those do its thing and then
hopefully these gilded play legs itself
alright so luckily enough after I did
drop the price what and played some
basketball got something to eat all of
this stuff did indeed sell we are at ten
point three for Mills I'm gonna find
something else in there I'm gonna wrap
up the episode here in a couple merges
so let's get right on into it
um don't know how to explain this but I
just bought a guest room for 295 and
sold it for 297 so an instant 2gp flip
let's go there we go so all of our trees
and strings have bought and sold which
just means I have to go back through and
buy back my treasonous rings and sell
these two and then we should be good to
go alright so if some of the stuff sold
off I think I might London on that which
I don't know if I did or not because
it's a really weird number to end on but
I'm going to collect all of this sell
off these scales and go to work I don't
think I'm gonna put my money into
anything because I don't know the
guilded never really works out for me so
I think I want to stay away from that
alright after changing the prices to
gilded plate legs have finally bought oh
my god no way just as soon as I got done
doing the last clip there we go all
three of those bought right so all of
the plate legs were
able to sell so that puts us at ten
point five seven mil which is actually
were really really nice so before I was
able to go actually one of the gilded
play leagues did indeed buy so we're
just gonna sell that back on and you
know make our 36 K back right so as we
expected the gilded plate like stood so
however the tyrannical ring also did buy
so it's kind of nerve-wracking because I
don't know what price is actually
selling for right now however the guy
price has not changed now never thought
it would sell but guess what there it is
alright guys this is going to be the end
of the video we are at ten point six
mils so a lot of progress was made this
episode I hope you guys enjoyed if you
did feel free to leave a like guys have
any way of which you would like me to
improve this series feel free to comment
that down below any suggestions is more
than helpful if you guys really enjoy my
content want to see more in the future
feel free to leave a sub other than that
I will be heading out so hopefully I get
to see you guys in the next video peace